this is a production of cornell
university
uh so thank you i'm actually very happy
to be here i in addition to being a
plant pathologist have an administrative
role and it's been to be quite frank a
rather rough administrative week so i'm
really happy to be talking about
tomatoes and research this afternoon
so
i
previously taught introductory plant
pathology and one of the things i would
always say is that tomatoes have about a
hundred diseases that attack them
but
that seems like a lot and it is a lot so
many diseases
the good news is that you know
the most common ones there's probably
only five or six really common diseases
uh that we see each year so
coming down from a hundred five or six
uh does not seem so bad
i wanted to start with a bit of a
timeline because right now this time of
year um what what we're doing
in our research greenhouses is we're
sanitizing we grow all of our
transplants for our research experiments
in our greenhouses
and
we want the transplants to be really
healthy going into the field because for
my research i want the plants to
you know become infected with the
pathogen that i inoculate with so it's
really critical
that the plants are healthy growing
going into the field of course as a
grower it's also really critical that
your plants are healthy going into the
field because
if they start out uh unhealthier you
know
it's not it's not going to vastly
improve you want to start with the best
possible uh scenario that you can
so
sam and i i sanitize the greenhouse
and i'll show you a picture of that in a
second but we sanitize benches we
sanitize the floor we have a concrete
floor on on the greenhouse that we grow
most of our transplants in
but we also have greenhouses that do
have um gravel floors and we would uh
sanitize those as well
trellising steaks i i will
bring up several times but uh sanitizing
trellising steaks is key
um and really anything that touches the
transplant whether that's flats or pots
or
you know anything that that might end up
touching a transplant
you're really going to want to sanitize
and then the other thing this time of
year or actually a couple of months ago
that you want to be thinking about is
when you're selecting your cultivars
in particular if you had a significant
disease outbreak in your tomatoes last
year you're going to want to think about
looking for resistant cultivars and i
know that you're going to tell me that
the resistant cultivars are not the ones
that consumers like myself always want
to buy
um but if you had an outbreak and had a
lot of yield loss last year
a resistant cultivar at least in part of
your crop
is really going to help you out this
year
so
uh the other thing uh i always ask my in
my introductory plant pathology is what
is the best way to control plant
diseases
and the students
nine tenths of the students will say you
spray fungicides
and and that that is not correct the
absolute best way to control plant
diseases is using cultural practices
which includes the use of resistant
varieties that plant breeders have
worked very very hard to develop
and that is your first and best line of
defense
so
uh important strategies for disease
control i'm going to start here and then
and then we're going to get into some
images of diseases so
starting with clean plants
that's clean seed
um there are
extension really actually really
beautiful extension publications on hot
water treatment of tomato seed i have
helped
tomato growers that are concerned and
particular about bacterial diseases hot
water treat their seed and the length of
time and the exact temperature are very
critical so if you are considering hot
water seed treatment
you really want an extremely accurate
thermometer and timer because you don't
want to leave them in that hot water too
long
clean your greenhouse
and all of the materials associated with
transplant production
and fuel production including charleston
stakes even if you had no disease last
year right because pathogens are tricky
they can survive in the greenhouse and
you might have had uh some bacteria on
the leaves in the greenhouse but you
didn't see the disease and then you put
it out in the field and it was okay this
might not be true for last year but it
let's say it was really dry that disease
would never have developed but
that pathogen could still be surviving
in the greenhouse so cleaning the
greenhouse every year even if you had no
disease last year is really a great way
to get started
the sanitizers work equally well as long
as you follow the label and really
importantly
clean the debris from the greenhouse or
the trellising steak prior to the
sanitation because as soon as that
sanitizer whether it's a green shield or
a zero tall as soon as any of them hit
organic matter they're going to become
inactive so you want to clean up all of
that plant debris anything that might be
covering up where the sanitizer might
need to get to the sanitizer wall
contact that pathogen kill it and then
become inactive
we keep our floors clean uh eliminate
weeds
as i said previously new or clean flats
and raise flats above the ground if you
can and always scout so this is a
picture of holly lang a former
technician
sanitizing our greenhouse um the benches
that we had at the time you can see they
had quite a bit of rust on the frame and
so she would just take a pump sprayer
and spray right along the edges and all
those nooks and crannies where
bacteria or fungal spores might like to
hide and she would spray each of the
benches she would also spray the gate
great and as well as the floor
we would sweep out the greenhouse ahead
of time to remove any organic matter
we would clean all of the surfaces and
then for flats
or pots that might be touching
transplants uh we actually dip those
into a
sterile such as green shield or or zero
tall
so this is a picture that i took uh in a
transplant tomato transplant production
facility in california
some time ago but i think it
illustrates nicely
the idea of if if there is
a
disease one plant
in this facility
that gets a pathogen gets a disease with
the overhead irrigation how tightly
packed things are and the high humidity
that pathogen will be able to spread
through these millions of plants really
quite quickly
so
scouting and
this uh this person right here
i was able to talk to him his entire job
40 hours a week was walking through
the transplant production facility
scouting
identifying where there's a disease
early on is going to enable you to get
rid of that get rid of the plants around
it because the pathogen has probably
already spread to them and move forward
so that the rest of your transplants do
not
get diseased and i realize that you know
most of us don't grow
eight million
uh tomato transplants at the same time
but the concepts are true whether you're
growing 200 plants or two million or two
million plants
so uh pathogens can be seed borne which
is why it's important to think about
transplant production
one infected seed in 10 000 can start an
epidemic in a greenhouse with these
overhead irrigation systems
and
the the pathogens can spread rapidly so
scouting is key
so that's what i'm doing at this time of
year
and sort of the next steps after getting
the plants into the field are okay what
diseases might we expect to see first
and
one of the one of the things we see
first
frequently in the year are bacterial
diseases
so i'm wondering and kim will put up a
poll how often do you see
symptoms
like like what you're seeing here on
these tomato fruit how often do you see
those on your farm do you see them every
year
most years
occasionally
never or you don't know
all right it looks like we are
stabilizing
around some years
and
a few folks every year
and a couple folks are fortunate that
they have not seen this
um
so
kim can
enter that
and that
[Music]
everyone can see where we landed
most people it looks like c bacterial
diseases
some
some years all right
the three common bacterial diseases we
have here in new york
are shown from left to right
bacterial speck
which is named because the lesion on the
fruit is very small like a speck
bacterial spec the
bacterium that causes this particular
disease
really thrives during cool seasons
bacterial canker
is
the bacterial pathogen that over the
years i've seen the most here in new
york has a very characteristic lesion
that i'll show several more times with
that
dark center
it can be
tan to brown center with that white halo
it's called a bird's eye lesion it's
very common as i said bacterial canker
likes cooler weather
but it'll it'll it'll show up in in most
seasons unless it's extremely hot and
dry
and then bacterial spot is the pathogen
we see other bacterial disease we see
most at least frequently and that's uh
because it really likes the really warm
wet season so when we get like hurricane
remnants with those hot uh blowing rains
it's common to see bacterial spot
so
how do we manage bacterial diseases
and
i wanted to put this here before i show
a few more images because i think it's
good to have some of these management
strategies in mind
so irrigation management is key
and
we want to water early in the day
and this is actually true for any um for
management of any pathogen
the the
more dry a leaf is the less chances you
are to have a disease if you water early
in the day so that the plants are dry by
nightfall you're gonna then if the if
there is a dew in the night you'll
spread that leaf wetness out you want
dry leaves
you want good air movement which helps
keep the leaves dry
and you don't want to
walk through the field or
prune greenhouse transplants when the
leaves are wet because when those leaves
are wet is when especially bacterial
diseases the sorry the bacteria
themselves can be on the surface of the
leaf they come out in the water and so
as you walk by the bacteria are going to
stick to you and then you're going to
transfer those to the next
plants
as i said before we want to make sure we
clean the trellising stakes
and copper can help prevent spread
amara were you going to jump in
i saw you look like you were going to
jump in
all right i turned my video on just to
be more friendly yeah
so
chris can i ask a quick question yes
marion um how are the bacteria getting
into the tomatoes
uh so the the bacteria it depends on
which pathogen we're looking at um and
i'll show some images in a minute but
they generally will enter either through
the
[Music]
wound so if there's a insect feeding or
hail damage or
the stomates which are the pores on the
leaves that enable the the plant to
breathe
or the hydathodes which are tiny holes
around the edge of the leaf so bacteria
are really tricky that way
um and on the fruit uh
we actually know that the bacteria will
get on the fruit and will enter
in when the fruit is very young in
little cracks that are in the fruit when
the fruit is a very young age
i did not inoculate this particular
tomato plant that has bacterial this
tomato fruit that has bacterial canker
but the the trellising steak next to it
had bacteria on it and this picture just
shows how
we know that bacteria can transfer from
the trellising steak to a tomato fruit
or or a tomato leaf and in fact i have a
colleague
at ohio state who the way that she
inoculates her research plots with
bacterial pathogens every year
is to simply use the trellising stakes
from the year before
right so at the end of the season she
pulls up those trellising stakes tosses
them in the barn the next season gets
them back out uses them again and that's
all she has to do to inoculate her field
plots
that should be enough to convince you to
disinfect those trellising steaks
so what we did is we actually
bought a
a trough that one would use for water
for cattle
and we put a disinfectant in that trough
and use the trough we dunk our steaks in
that trough we leave our steaks in the
disinfectant the sterolant
for
about 10 to 15 minutes
and we'll put we want to make sure that
all of the stakes are in contact with
the solution so
we probably only put about 25 stakes in
at a time
just to make sure that there's contact i
get asked a lot how do you know for how
long is that disinfectant usable how
long is it good
and um
i have not tried these but i know there
are um test kits that you can actually
use to see if your disinfectant is still
effective um but we tend
to use it um for about about two we use
it for about 200 steaks right so we use
it for eight batches
we do uh clean our steaks first so
there's no organic matter left on them
but we assume that there are still
there's still organic matter in the
nooks and crannies
i did want to get a few more images of
the bacterial diseases before i move on
um
bacterial canker the bacterium that
causes bacterial canker is
somewhat unique because it will actually
travel through the veins of the plant uh
in the xylem itself the the water
conducting vesicle vessels and it will
clog those vessels you can see on the
edge of the leaf right here this
necrosis
and um
as i said earlier the
pathogen can actually enter in tiny
holes that are along the edges of these
leaves and that's how you that's how it
develops this necrosis one tricky thing
is that a lot of things can cause
marginal necrosis on a tomato leaf so
that marginal necrosis by itself is
it is not oh i have marginal necrosis
it's absolutely bacterial canker because
other things can cause that as well
these birds eye lesions on the fruit are
an absolute diagnostic sign there's
nothing else that causes lesions like
that
this
was from a farm that did not recognize
that it had bacterial canker and it just
turned into a total loss of this tomato
field uh the plants wilted and
all of the fruit were had some
symptom some lesion on it which made it
unmarketable the other thing i wanted to
show you was just sort of what what does
this bacterium look like it's yellow and
it's slimy and so you can imagine how if
that were in the water conducting vessel
of your tomato
it might clog it up
all right bacterial speck is the other
uh bacterial pathogen that we have seen
frequently in recent years until 2009 we
really almost never saw it here in new
york in 2009 we had a very cool wet
season and every year since then we've
had some bacterial speck in the state
as you can see the lesions are very
small
but do make the fruit unmarketable it is
particularly severe you can see
here i like this image because there are
a lot of leaves that don't have any
symptoms but then you can see there's
one leaf that does have symptoms and um
you know i we don't yet know why why it
is that
this leaf really
the bacteria were able to enter compared
to the one right next door to it
but that's one of the questions that
we're looking at
we know that bacterial spec that
actually all of the bacterial pathogens
do have the ability to survive on farm
we also know that they can also and do
also arrive in seed or transplants
all of the bacteria will spread by
wind-blown rain and water splashing as
well
and one of the things that i want to
highlight i frequently get asked well
how come on my on my tomato plant some
of the fruit will have those bacterial
spots and others won't
and the reason for that is the timing
when the bacteria land on the fruit
so if the bacteria
land on a tomato fruit when it's less
than one inch in diameter so less than
roughly the size of a golf ball you're
going to end up seeing spots on that
fruit
and the bacteria
can actually enter even when the flower
is wide open that tiny fruit is just
starting to develop it can enter there
and those lesions
will stay on the fruit and that's what
you see when the fruit is fully mature
once the fruit gets to be larger than
one inch in diameter i had a
student that graduated not too long ago
and he actually took the bacterial
canker pathogen with a paintbrush and
painted it on to all sorts of tomato
fruits and once those fruits are larger
than an inch in diameter it doesn't
matter how many bacteria you paint on
with that paint brush they do not they
do not get symptoms so um it's really
in terms of the fruit um
the symptoms are
or the disease can only infect the
pathogen can only affect when the fruit
are young
so as i said uh sort of wrapping up my
bacterial diseases uh
they're they're much worse and this is
true of most but not all
plant diseases are going to be much
worse in wet summers
we know our bacteria survive both in
greenhouses and and they can survive on
farm over winter
they can arrive on seed
there are very limited options for
bacterial diseases and one of the things
my group does every year
is test potential new options for
control and i would say maybe 10 years
ago i was really excited because there
was a company that was producing tiny
viruses called bacteriophage and those
bacteriophage are super specific to the
back to one particular bacterium and
they'll kill it so it's like a virus
that goes in and only kills the
bacterial kanger pathogen
we tried it but it didn't work so last
year a different company had a new
product and and i still feel like
there's there's a lot of promise in this
biological control strategy and so the
one we tried last year
uh worked better than nothing at all
so that was good but it did not work as
well as the the copper that we put on so
copper is the most commonly used uh
control strategy
and
uh bacteria in terms of timing
bacterial pathogens can arrive any time
of the season
but it is one of the diseases that you
can see early in the season particularly
if it came through transplants
my lab is tested bacteria for copper
resistance there there's known copper
resistance in almost every uh bacterial
pathogen
and we saw some
in the bacterial spot pathogen bacterial
spot because it loves that warm humid
weather
is actually a limiting factor for tomato
production in florida and
we think that
some transplants came up that had
bacterial spot with some copper
resistance but we really haven't seen
widespread copper resistance here in new
york
i will say
that uh in some instances
there can be too much copper put onto a
plant you know the in this case the
copper was not phytotoxic um
but you can see that on the plat the
plastic is just blue uh with copper
and you know the grower was worried
about rain and
did not had a history of bacterial
diseases and was spraying copper on a
five-day five-day schedule so
when you do have bacterial pathogens
they can be devastating and
control strategies can be limited
all right
so
if there are questions on bacterial
pathogens otherwise we will have a poll
on early blight
how often do you see early blight on
your farm
marian abby amara did i miss anything in
bacteria
while people are answering the poll
hey chris it's abby um i remember that
at one point you were doing
i don't know maybe it was maybe it
wasn't was it blackrock i don't know if
you did this in tomatoes but you had a
way to know whether the bacteria was
being brought in on seed more frequently
than
overwintering and i don't know if you
have a sense of that with the tomato
bacterial diseases
yeah so for
we do for bacterial canker um
the the
path the bacterium that causes bacterial
spec they all seem to be extremely it's
really hard to differentiate them
bacterial canker we do know
that
it's about a 50 50 mix of
the the pathogen overwintering on farm
and new strains coming in each year
and for bacterial spot i have a student
that's working on that right now we
don't have quite enough uh
we don't have quite enough
isolates of the pathogen yet to do that
study
okay okay thanks
early
blight everyone sees it some years
uh in my
in my plots and in my home garden i seem
to see it every year
so
the
trademark symptom
of early blight is this target-shaped
lesion on the tomato leaf
and early blight also goes to the tomato
stem
and some people say it looks like a
target on the stem
i have a bit of a harder time always
seeing that but on the leaves you get
these very characteristic target shaped
lesions
when early blight is young
it's really hard to differentiate um
from other pathogens
and i will show you an example of that
in a second
so when the early when you see early
symptoms there are small dark lesions
which there are several other pathogens
that also cause small dark lesions
including bacterial speck and septoria
the older leaves have these older
lesions are target-shaped
and early blight the fungus that causes
uh this disease the fungus has a kind of
cool name alternaria to monophylla i i
like that one um it survives in the soil
and it will you'll first see it on the
lower leaves and it'll splash up from
the soil onto those lower leaves
so
uh
rotation is key because the pathogen is
in the soil if you can rotate out of
tomato and
this this particular pathogen can go to
potato and there's a super closely
related pathogen that and they can both
sort of go to potato and tomato so
you're going to want to rotate away from
potato and tomato and they're going to
be worse than wet weather because well
pathogens like wet weather but also
you're likely to get that splashing up
so in addition to rotation anything you
can do if you have a weed cloth or a
straw mulch or something on the ground
to try to prevent splashing from the
soil up onto the plant that's really
going to help you control early blight
so these are young early blight region
early blight lesions
small dots on a leaf
and they look remarkably similar to
these septoria lesions and these
bacterial spec lesions so when someone
brings a leaf like this into my lab i i
can't i can't differentiate the three
when they're that small i actually have
to isolate and and see which pathogen
that we're working with
early blood as i said is an annual
problem
um
you'll see lesions as you can see in
this plant starting on the lower leaves
but then they'll move up rapidly and
it's that splashing up the plant um from
either overhead watering or or
rain events that really will move it
through the plant quickly and it can it
can take a plant down
and i'm including septoria here we're
gonna i'm gonna talk about management
because they
you manage them both in a similar manner
so
have you guys seen septoria on your farm
septoria leaf spot
is uh
these tiny uh spots here as you saw on
the previous slide
the characteristic lesion that you see
over here on the right hand side is a
dark ring with a tan center and tiny
black spots and there's there's nothing
else that looks like an old septoria
lesion
and
it can be
confusing uh with early blight
especially at some of the the younger
stages and a lot of times you're going
to see both septoria and early blight
together
and then you're it's like i'm not sure
and that's usually because it's both
and i think that shows up in this poll
because a lot of times you might be
seeing it and you're like i'm not sure i
had brown spots on my leaf but i'm not
sure what fungus or what organism was
causing um
uh these these brown spots
so
whoa
sorry about that
there we go
um
septoria leaf spot as i said comes uh it
survives over winter in this in the soil
just like the early blight pathogen
splashes up onto the leaves these are
again those characteristic lesions
they're they're getting a bit older you
can see this tan spots starting to
develop in the center
um
the
as i said it's confused with other spots
and the other thing that's tricky about
it is that it's seen mid to late season
which is the time when you're going to
see almost all of the tomato pathogens
showing up so that can make it tricky as
well
much like early blight it
thrives in the wet years as the fungus
splashes from the soil to the lower
leaves um
i was i was visiting a grower and
actually it might have been with abby
um
and there was one field on their farm
that they took us to because they knew
so when i
visit farms people tend to to show me
their most diseased plants and um
this particular field was in a remote
area of the farm and it had been
forgotten about
and so no control strategies were used
and the entire field was destroyed
by the combination of septoria and early
blight and you can see in this field
they did have a black plastic mulch and
a straw mulch between the rows and even
with that the fungus was able to move
from the soil up onto the plants and
completely wipe out this field it was a
total loss it was really sad
this is an image of of that field you
can see
they tried to go in and see if they
could harvest anything
but in fact it was a total loss
so managing early blight and septoria
rotation is important scouting is
important because you're going to want
to
see oh i have a lesion right on the
bottom of the plant you can remove those
lower leaves
that will help
and
as soon as you see scout and see that
first lesion if you're going to
implement a
control strategy
whether it's one of the effective
fungicides
there are
bio controls that from i haven't tested
them but from what i've read have mixed
efficacy you know you're going to want
to do that early on so you're going to
want to scout oh there's a lesion now
it's when i need to really start
focusing on disease control there are
tolerant varieties
the varieties that most growers commonly
grow
because that's what the market wants are
susceptible but there are tolerant
varieties available
all right
that was early blight and septoria
tomato leaf mold
have you guys seen this on your farm
uh my lab didn't only started working on
tomato leaf mall um
five years ago
and uh
it's really because of the increase in
high tunnel tomato production in new
york
that we started working on tomato leaf
mold
and
in this group
it seems that most folks thankfully have
not seen tomato leaf mold
um
but the the person who sees it most
years or the people that see it most
years i'm guessing they that you have
some high tunnel tomato production
because that's where we see it most
often
so these are our research high tunnels
and so we were able to do tomato leaf
mold experiments in our research high
tunnels
we could inoculate plants
which i would never want to do on a
grower farm
but we
did several different research projects
on
tomato leaf mold in our high tunnels and
this is kelly inoculating some of our
plants
tomato leaf mold is common in high
tunnels because it likes hot and humid
conditions and it likes cool nights and
that's exactly what you have in a high
tunnel scenario it
if it if you have plants in the field
and it's a rainy season you're probably
not going to see leaf mold it just does
not like the rain nope don't want my
leaves wet which is unusual for a
pathogen
so it likes those hot humid conditions
and it actually needs a very high
humidity to for those spores to
germinate and attack the plant but um no
rain
it can spread rapidly you see on the
upper leaf surface you
surface you see these yellow spots and
then on the lower leaf surface you can
see uh this
brown to gray i think people tend to
call it sort of an olive color colored
uh fuzz those are actually all spores of
the fungus and there are so many spores
that that once it gets started those
spores just can spread like wildfire
through a high tunnel
and we tend to see this mid to late
season
because it does it
the pathogen will survive over the
winter in the high tunnel
on plant debris generally
but it takes a while
for it to get established and then move
throughout the high tunnel during the
season
so how do we control tomato leaf mold
well as i said it over winter is in the
tunnel so we remove debris and and i
know
this this can be difficult for growers
but rotating the high tunnel out of
tomato will really help reduce the
incidence of tomato of tomato leaf mold
um
especially since it's surviving in that
in that tunnel
how long chris is one year enough for do
you need more than one no that's a great
question one year at least um from what
i have read we haven't done the
rotational studies but one year should
be enough because that tomato debris
breaks down fairly quickly yeah if if
you have some really big stems it might
take longer but generally one year is
enough
one of the the
i don't know drawbacks is not the right
word but
generally um if you have high tunnels
you might have three or four next to one
another and you can imagine if it's hot
out and you roll up the sides and you
have this many
spores of the tomato leaf mold fungus in
one tunnel they can spread pretty
rapidly to the one right next door to it
so that
if all of the high tunnels are in a line
it it can be tricky to try to rotate
away or or keep one tunnel um
leaf mold free
uh one of one of the places when i'm
scouting a high tunnel
if uh if i see that there are sun gold
uh fruit which i am a huge fan of the
sun gold tomato
i will go and scout those plants first
because in any given high tunnel the sun
gold is going to be the cultivar that
gets the tomato leaf mold first
sadly it's incredibly susceptible
so i i did want to show a little bit of
data on our
high tunnel leaf mold trial um i had a
student that recently graduated that did
a lot of work and we made some progress
understanding the leaf mold that we have
here in new york
and there was some concern there are
tomato varieties that are grown in high
tunnels that
have are are sold as resistant to tomato
leaf mold and there was some concern
that the resistance might be breaking
down but in our studies
we
we the four cultivars that are targeted
as resistant to tomato leaf mold uh were
resistant in our study as well so in
this graph along the x-axis we have the
tomato cultivars that we trialed and we
rated at four different dates so the the
blue bar is the first rating the orange
bar the second the gray bar the third
and the gold bar the final rating of the
season and on the um
on the y-axis we have
the percent disease um from zero to 100
percent so you can see by the by the
final rating uh some of the cultivars in
our high tunnel had a a lot of disease
but the good news was there were uh
cultivars that did have resistance as
well
so
that was tomato leaf mold chris can i
ask you one more question first
um
could someone plant a resistant tomato
variety instead of rotating out of
tomatoes all together
so if your only focus is tomato leaf
malt then yes absolutely
and and
we
we know that the pathogen has been in
high tunnels in new york for a long time
making lots of spores and we have not
yet seen the pathogen mutate to overcome
that host resistance however we also
know that there are
other pathogens um soil-borne pathogens
that uh that that will build up and can
wipe out a tomato crop so it is good to
rotate if if you can
especially to to get away from some of
the soil pathogens that you might have
and some of the soil insects that you
might have in that high tunnel
and in
sort of along those lines for for
reasons that i'm very curious about but
do not yet understand
there's a disease called white mold and
in tomato and pepper in high tunnels it
seems to almost be worse
in high tunnels it survives in the soil
as well and i i'm i'm really wanting to
do some studies to try to understand why
it is that the high tunnel environment
is worse for for those particular soil
borne pathogens
compared to the field environment
as an aside
questions to be answered
so chris i have another question about
leaf mold can um
can keeping keeping the air moving in a
high tunnel is there any kind of
like um air movement or air
or humidity management tech techniques
that can
can contribute to management
yeah um
any you know so that would be spacing of
rose
um
you know when for sure uh
one of uh
one of my uh most interesting memories
of tomato leaf mold um was i was in in
the north country visiting a grower
and walking through the tunnel and you
know tomato plants this was in august
and they're huge in high tunnels by then
and the rows were very close together so
i was actually walking sideways to get
through the row and when i came out of
that high tunnel i was completely
covered in tomato leaf mold fungus
spores
and um and and and that just sort of
reminded me anytime i think about row
spacing and high tunnels and i talked to
the grower and you know they said well i
really want to have as many tomatoes as
possible because i want the biggest
harvest because you know it
i need my farm to be profitable
um but reducing those number of rows and
giving the plants a bit more space
pruning out to increase the air flow
within a plant will all help reduce not
only leaf mold but any of the other
pathogens that you might have
thanks
so i would say five years ago
i would lead off
every single
tomato talk
with late blight
because it was by far and away
the biggest issue
for tomato growers in the state of new
york um
they were fearful of it um and and just
thought wow uh if i get late blight
my crop is wiped out
and
and
over the past five to maybe seven years
the amount of late blight that we've
seen
in tomato in new york or even in potato
in new york has really declined to the
point where i am now uh including this
and at the at the as the last disease
that i talk about
um
which is interesting
so people see it some years
um
if you have late blight
it's definitely
going to impact your your farm
in this slide i i wanted to show a
diversity of the symptoms that we might
see
in a young tomato fruit you're going to
see a lesion like this brown lesion on
the left hand side
you frequently don't see
as many of the pathogen spores
on the younger
very green fruit so you'll see a brown
um lesion out like the picture here on
the left
this leaf here in the center is an image
that i frequently use
because it's it's like the
characteristic image of tomato late
light that just
millions of spores of the pathogen that
show up on the underside of the leaf
and will
their wind barn fly through the air and
can cause
a huge amount of disease in a really a
relatively short period of time
the pathogen can also attack the stem of
the plant and you can see here on a
tomato stem here's a leaf lesion here's
a stem lesion with so many of those
white
spores on the stem
and then in a ripe fruit
this is sort of the extreme close up but
again you can see
that the pathogen is just really
devastating that
ripe fruit
so late light is caused by a water mold
it looks like a fungus
but it's actually it's quite
evolutionarily different from a fungus
and there are a couple of things
that make that really important to
understand if you're growing tomatoes
and one of those is that
um this particular uh well water molds
in general will go completely crazy
in cool wet weather
and in this image that i have here on
the left
at first you look and you think oh
that's a healthy tomato plant but when
you look at it closer
you can see
that there are lesions on the leaves of
these tomato plants
and
this is probably not yet
close to five percent of that tomato
plant has some light blight on it
and
my lab has done quite a few studies that
once
that tomato plant gets to five percent
disease which is really not very much
it's
nearly impossible
to control this pathogen especially if
it rains
so
that's why
you know we're all so nervous about late
blight you know if you have five percent
bacterial disease you can still think
about slowing it down but but wow it's
really hard to slow lay blight down
um the lesions can grow really rapidly
it's so common to hear people say you
know i was in the field yesterday and i
didn't see it and today the plants are
dead
and
and they can grow really rapidly it can
spread fast um
and it will attack as i showed earlier
the leaves the fruit and the stems
back to that characteristic white
sporulation
and i thought i would spend a second uh
talking about that because this is a
close-up of those spores
and what they do is in the they're
formed overnight
and in the morning when the humidity
decreases the sun comes out those spores
actually twist in the lower humidity and
twist their way right off the leaf into
the wind of the morning and they spread
to other leaves in the same plant other
plants in the same field and the fields
next door
we know that we need to worry about
where is that original late blight
inoculum coming from and we also know
that
the pathogen is is not very good at
surviving the winter here in new york
which is a really great thing about
winter it kills slate light for the most
part
one of the ways that it will survive the
winter here in new york is in potato
tubers that are not harvested if a
potato field got late light this
pathogen goes to both tomato and potato
also petunia
and this is a potato tuber that is
infected with the late blight pathogen
if this tuber sprouts that new sprout
will have light blight and it can spread
so it's really important sanitation is
so critical for this particular pathogen
i wanted to highlight i encourage you
all to go to the website called
usablite.org
um it has lots of resources on lake
blight and you can sign up for text
messages that will actually tell you if
the pathogen has been identified in your
in in our region of new york in addition
to that
if we identify late blight in in new
york state any of us we push that out
through social media and all of our
weekly newsletters
late blight is somewhat unique among pla
amongst plant pathogens because
uh it's characterized by by strains so
you saw all of those spores those spores
are all the same strain they're all
identical and if the pathogen
overwinters in that potato tuber and
comes back the next year it's still the
exact same strain
and since
2011
we have had the same strain in the state
of new york and its name is us-23
and there are some really interesting
things about this strain which i think
is why we have not seen late blight as
aggressive as we have we had maybe um
five to ten years ago
it's sensitive uh to the fungicides that
can be used to control it
it's more aggressive on tomato than
potato so you're less likely to get
those overwintering potato tubers
and
a nice thing about it is we've done
studies that show that copper can
control this particular strain if the
copper is applied early
so even though we have not had much late
light recently we still need to be
really vigilant
and the last thing that i wanted to show
um was that there are some resistant uh
some tomato varieties that are resistant
to late light
and
this picture of the variety trial that
we had
these are individual plots here and
those plants are flat out dead
but
you can see that there are plots where
the plants are still alive
and
that's really exciting
because
if if we know if
let's say 2022 we have a horrible
outbreak of late light and we think that
there will be late blight in 2023 as
well
you could plant some of these resistant
tomato cultivars knowing that even if
there was light blight you would get a
tomato crop it might not be your
favorite cultivar that you've ever eaten
in your whole life but you would get a
tomato crop
and um
the the genes
are known that enable this resistance
they're called ph2 and ph3
and here are some of the um varieties
that
are resistant to lake light and it's you
know some of them are are ones that are
now um grown
so
we were really happy to see that some
um tomato varieties were holding up
against the most common strain of lake
light
so
controlling light blight
using those resistant varieties scouting
is key
you have to catch that so early
um especially if it's a cool and wet
season
um if you're going to use uh fungicides
we there are effective fungicides
available
rotating
fungicides is key as i said copper has
some efficacy
importantly if you think you have late
light let one of us know we'll get a
sample and um we'll make sure that it's
late light and uh help with any
issues might you might have in in
controlling the pathogen
it'll spread quickly to other plants and
and to other fields so remove and
destroy
uh infected plants as rapidly as
possible
so we're back to the best way to control
plant diseases
cultural practices are your first and
best defense i hope i've outlined some
of the cultural practices that you can
use
um
and with that i will thank the people in
my lab that did the work
the growers that led us onto their farms
my cce and ipm colleagues and all of our
work is funded both by the state of new
york and by the usda
so thank you and i will take questions
thank you so much chris um yes if
anybody has any questions can you please
put them in the chat um i have a quick
one to get us started with um i know we
had a question yesterday someone was
asking about when they see diseases um
it's usually too late do you have
thresholds for the different diseases
that people should be looking for when
do they need to act
yeah there are there are thresholds for
many of the many of the diseases um
those would be those would be
listed in in um
the vegetable guidelines but generally
um
you know
um
generally it's
well so if if it's on your farm if it's
a bacterial disease or
early blight septoria
i would say
as soon as you see lesions in the plant
that's going to be your threshold if
it's late light your threshold is if
it's in the county
right so
you might you you hope that your farm is
not the first farm in the county to have
lab lights but that's one of the reasons
that we really want everyone to scout
and let us know because once there is a
farm in the county or a nearby county
that has uh late blight that's going to
be our threshold to start thinking about
the best management
strategies
all right great um are there any
questions i don't see any yet in the
chat if anybody wants to write in their
questions or
more than happy to unmute yourself if
you would like you can ask questions too
so i had a question about um
i think this is uh
in relationship to high tunnels but uh
if you plant spinach in the in the fall
um after tomatoes and harvest in the
spring harvest that spinach uh and then
plow under
and you plant again the next season is
that considered a rotation so you know
you took your tomatoes out in september
you put spinach in
and then you want to put tomatoes back
in in
april is that considered a rotation and
you know
i think it i i my answer would be no
um
you really need a season you know a year
a season out of tomato
it is possible with the tilling if
you're really getting rid of all the
leaf debris that you might not have a
leaf mold issue
but in terms of some of the soil
pathogens i would say stay a whole year
out
ah so 40 sungold tomatoes in your high
tunnel first off uh please invite me
over
i love them um
uh
and uh recommendations to avoid leaf
mold so um
uh you know that air spacing is critical
and um
uh
the most effective thing
we've yeah so first air spacing second
scout
be on the lookout and when you scout it
it's actually it's actually fairly easy
when you're looking across the high
tunnel look for any anytime you see a
yellow spot
and yellow yellow spots can be caused by
a lot of things but one of them is leaf
mold so then you see that yellow spot
you flip the leaf over and see if you
have that gray mold
um
and then uh
the other thing is that if if you are
planning um
to use a control strategy you're going
to want to start as soon as you see that
first lesion
and so scouting is really really key
but yeah that that making sure that
you're
pruning you know
leaves the lower leaves get rid of those
so there's there's more air flow and um
that that should be yeah that should be
good
abby is also yes if you if you
yes share them with the ipm house
so chris i had a
question about um
fungicide strategy for
late blight because
i um
i know that
so mostly it's us 23 and so
going in with rid you know with
methanoxam is probably the right thing
to do
um
sometimes i think growers want to wait
and find out if it's
uh us 23 but would you recommend that
they just
go ahead with the methanoxin whether
they know or not if it's susceptible
yeah so if the if the
late light is in the field yeah then yes
absolutely
um
because
in in 11 years
the predominant
uh late blight we've seen has been
sensitive to methanoxin so absolutely
and then you also mentioned um fungicide
rotation
so i know that so in general is there
like a
class of fungicides that's you know
better in rotation with methanoxin like
should it be
um trans laminar or
what what what is it about a good
rotation fungicide would you recommend
yeah so i think that
uh
translator yes um
the
the those fungicides that are effective
on
the oh my seats you know the
um the revis the presidios the
arandis right um they tend to be really
expensive and so you want to use those
you know
on a limited basis because we don't want
resistance but also because they're very
expensive um so i think that um uh
alternating um something that's
translaminar um and affordable with
uh you know something something that's
more expensive is the best strategy and
particularly with this um this u.s 23 we
have seen success with that um so but
those you know the the rand man the
presidio the revis the
the orondis are all very effective okay
thanks
um chris you have one more question but
i also know you have to hop off so if
you have a chance to answer it yep
biologicals yeah so so we uh biological
fungicides for bacteria we have trials
every year um
and uh
we had
last year
the
the we had the phage that i talked about
um we also had double nickel and um
double nickel after after copper double
nickel actually worked the best and
that's uh
bacillus
and um that that was effective we have
tried regalia against bacterial diseases
and we have not seen any efficacy we've
also tried oxidate
we tried lifeguard we've tried a lot of
different
products and
so far
you know bacteria are really hard but um
so far um the the double nickel uh we've
seen the the
best sort of
it not as good as copper but in that
next best category and we'll be trying
actually additional um biologicals this
year i'm actually i'm hopeful that you
know that there is now a group of
scientists that are studying you know
what can really survive on that leaf
surface and you know
if we can really learn about what
survives on the leaf surface or how do
we enable those biologicals to survive
on the leaf surface i think i think that
will really help propel
biologicals um
into a you know into a place where we
can
we we need to find ways to help the
biological survive uh and out compete
that pathogen
great so we're going to be going over
nutrition and fertility management for
tomatoes uh
in general and then as i go through the
talk i'm going to try to be pointing out
how it relates to ipm
so as we go through this feel free to
put questions in the chat um
we'll get to those questions at the end
of the session
so here we go
fundamentals of nutrition is a place i
always like to start so we're going to
go over the plant needs the relationship
of ph and soil fertility and then also
uptake inhibition
so
what does the tomato need this is pulled
straight out of the the recommendations
or guidelines that cornell puts out and
right across the top we'll see that it's
based for soil for transplants in the
background we don't really
i don't know anyone who does direct
seeding in new york
we have bare ground transplants and then
we also have separate recommendations
for transplants in plastic mulch and the
reason they're separated out is not
because the overall tour recommendation
is different that is the same like you
see in the blue
um it's because
what you do with broadcasts and disking
is different
when plants are on plastic mulch they
very often have trickle irrigation
underneath
and so we're going to spoon feed those
plants throughout the season that's why
you're broadcasting less in
right across the top we see a range of
nutrient levels for potassium
and for phosphorus
the
number the largest number that's what
the plant needs the medium and high
that's adjusting that recommendation
downwards based on your soil test
so that's how you read these if you have
and i've said soil test right so
how much do you add
very much so the management of your
fertility should always be based on the
soil test you want to be testing your
soil
at least every three years if you've
made some sort of change to soil either
adding a lot of amendments
or maybe you had the field manured
last summer you know if your early crop
of peas came off you had to feel ignored
or if you've done a lot of ph adjustment
you want to retest so every lab will
have a slightly different extraction
method the important thing is that
you're looking at the pounds per acre or
the sufficiency bars
and then if you switch from labs to lab
until the numbers the values may not
line up but the sufficiency bars will
so
very quickly we can look to see that
this field is very high in phosphorus
it's high in potassium very high in
calcium and high in magnesium overall
pretty good fertility
uh four things you should check out in
addition to those bars you should check
out the soil ph
that's going to give you a lot of
information about what nutrients may or
may not be available you want to check
out the percent organic matter because
that's related to
so many things but in terms of fertility
it's related mostly to nitrogen cycling
and it's related to the soil's ability
to hold on store nutrients and then give
them back up later
your soil test should always go in with
a name the series name of your soil if
it goes in with the name then the
recommendations coming out are going to
be better tailored to your soil the soil
name tells the lab if you have a clay
soil a sandy soil something in between
and then at the bottom the lab is giving
recommendations for what you add you'll
see that labs almost always
recommend 50 pounds of phosphorus for a
tomato crop
and we'll get into why that is
even though the phosphorus is very very
high
lots of labs will recommend that because
they're trying to overcome a temporary
deficiency caused by cold soils
and that's a management decision that
you know along an ipm standpoint might
not always make sense
so we always want to aim to optimize
things that ipm is just as much about
prevention as it is about
uh sustainability right and so
optimizing your ph and fertility makes a
ton of sense to do that so i'll start
with this little graphic down here this
is a barrel it's a very common analogy
for how you think about fertility and
what's limiting your crop every stave in
the barrel is a different nutrient along
the front they've written the
macronutrients along the back they've
written the micronutrients and inside
you fill it up with water and the water
is your yield potential
your yield in terms of nutrition is only
going to be able to go as high as your
most limiting nutrient and that's where
the water is spilling out in this case
it's potassium i particularly like this
barrel because oftentimes i think in
tomatoes our yield and our quality is
more limited by potassium than by
anything else
so when you have fertility that's too
low either your your gross fertility so
that's your overall
plant fertility or your specific
fertility of one nutrient you end up
with plants that are stressed in some
way and stress plants are more
susceptible to diseases and insects
insufficient levels of fertility for
specific nutrients can often interfere
with fruiting and fruit quality
and this idea of sufficiency also
applies to water stress so that's going
to mean that yes we're talking about
fertility but if your plants are
constantly going through drought
flooding cycles
they're not functioning very well and so
you've created an artificial
temporary inability to get nutrients
in terms of ph being too low
we often find that when the ph drops the
macronutrients become unavailable
they're present in the soil but the
plant can't get them
and that the micronutrient availability
in the soil goes way up and that can
cause some toxicity problems
on the flip side if we're running too
much infertility too high very fertile
soils
yes the plants are doing really well but
as you continue to put more fertilizer
into that soil you're really wasting
money especially this year fertilizer
costs were up 80 to 100 percent over
last year in western new york and that
was as of mid-february they've continued
to go up this is not the year to be
excessively applying fertilizer from an
economic standpoint
um if we get too much of certain
nutrients we can start seeing some
uptake problems caused by other things
so this is where we start to see some
inhibition and some competition
one example of this is if you are
fertilizing very heavily with a nh4 plus
so an ammonium
style fertilizer the ammonium
is in competition with potassium for
uptake in the soil
and
if you give your plants a giant slug of
ammonium you can cause a temporary
decrease in the availability and uptake
of potassium and a temporary
insufficiency in your plants instead if
you're feeding with nitrate no three
minus
format the plant uses that much more
efficiently it's not competing for
uptake
i'm a weed scientist
i always look at how can we control
weeds with our ipm
sorry with our ipm toolbox
and one of the easiest things we can do
is not feed them
weeds love fertility and there's so much
better using it than most of our crops
and so they are hoarding it in
especially pigweeds they're going to
collect more nutrition than they can
possibly
use and they hold it so other plants can
have it but they're also growing really
big selling lots of seed so
it's a it's a strong ipm tactic um too
much fertility can favor certain pests
and diseases i'll give examples of that
later it also interferes with brooding
and fruit quality and
environmentally irresponsible
if we look at ph as ph gets too high we
tend to see micronutrients they're in
the soil but they're no longer available
to the plants and we start to see
deficiencies this is really common for
manganese it's common for zinc and it's
common for iron and the place that we
see those problems is in the transplant
production stage when we're not actually
using
soil
when we're using some sort of starter
mix the ph rises in those and we start
seeing
yellow in the new shoots slow growth out
diminished leaf size those are micro
nutrient deficiencies in the transplants
because the ph of the growing media has
gotten too high
actual micronutrient deficiencies in the
field are very rare
outside i've never seen it it does
happen in tunnels from time to time
because the ph of the soil has gotten
too high
so i keep talking about ph and nutrient
availability this is the chart that
shows it across the bottom we've got the
ph of the soil and each of these
different colored bars is a nutrient
the top set up through magnesium right
about here halfway down those are the
macronutrients below that are the
micronutrients
and you can see most of our tomato crops
most recommendations say around 6.5
and at 6.5 the width of the band that's
available to the plants really matches
how much that they need and so this is
why we're aiming at 6.5 it naturally
balances the amount of nutrition that
the plants need against the availability
of those nutrients in the soil
we can have all the fertility we need
but if the plants can't get at its it
doesn't matter so i always like to look
at what could be inhibiting the uptake
i keep talking about tunnels because a
lot of tomatoes end up being grown
inside so it's very common in tunnels
that we get an accumulation of salts
and they rise up and they're going in
with
manure's base compost they're going in
with
poultry based fertility pellets they're
going in with our liquid fertilizers
those rise up through the soils water
evaporates leaving the salts and salts
they change the osmotic pressure and
they start inhibiting the roots ability
to pick up nutrients
uh the other thing in the field
compaction is huge and so this is a
giant wet spot someone decided i really
have to drive through this i can't find
another way around and just compacted
the soil
you have already had drainage issues
you're just going to keep on causing
more drainage issues and more uptake
problems and so a lot of times fertility
problems will chase water issues or
chase compaction issues
other things that inhibit nutrition
fertility from an ipm standpoint
if i'm seeing a fertilizer fertility
problem and it's not uniform okay
fertility problem is caused by feeding
our uniform across your field
um if it's not uniform then i want to
check out the roots in that area
especially it's kind of like a circular
pattern
this is a nice healthy tomato plant
in case you haven't dug up roots of one
recently that's what you want but things
like nematodes can have a big impact on
the apparent
nutrition status of your plant so can
root rots
freezerium and verticillium are two
wilts we see verticillium sometimes in
high tunnels
uh it's oftentimes because we're seeing
different heirlooms being grown in there
that don't have the genetic resistance
to it ferticilium is going to darken up
the veins and so we test for it by
splitting the veins if you've ever
raised an eggplant you will know what
versilium what will does it takes out
half a leaf or one branch with wilting
and yellowing and then scorching
fusarium will is more of a generalized
yellowing that eventually progresses to
a scorch
and a wilty plant this can be confused
sometimes for a nitrogen deficiency
both of these will inhibit how well the
plants functioning so you get a
appearance of a nutrient deficiency
any questions at this point
i can't see the chat so are we good
marion so far so good yep okay
so the other thing with optimizing is
the timing and the ratios of what you're
feeding so plants really are they are
feed me now they have a generalized
growth curve and their growth curve
follows the uptake curve right so in
general it's this s-shaped curve they
have this lag phase when they're little
a rapid growth phase when they have a
high nutrient demand and then their
nutrient demand levels off
so let's say this is nitrogen we have
these little baby transplants they're
growing but they're not really taking
off yet
we get into the quick vigorous growth
phase that's when you want to time your
nitrogen feed right here this is a
reason why the recommendations for
tomatoes under plastic
said that you're going to cut your
fertility back because we're planting it
you know under plastic we often have
drip and you're spoon feeding the whole
purpose of spoon feeding is not to waste
your fertility down here
is to feed it when you have much more
fertilizer use efficiency
and target the plants in their
developmental stage where they need that
so if you miss these growth curves you
could be stressing your plants if you
give a lot of your nitrogen broadcast in
the field not only are you feeding your
weeds you're also increasing the chance
that that's going to leach out with with
spring rains and that translates to
stress loss yield
if you miss the shift in the potassium
uptake needs then you're going to be
leading to poor fruit quality and so
potassium has a delayed shift we'll
switch to the other side here talk about
balance in the center
tomato plants when they're young you
want to be feeding primarily for
nitrogen management for npk you're
feeding mostly for nitrogen management
as they begin flowering you're feeding
that plant for potassium management they
have a much greater physiological need
as a flower as they set fruit and need
to load sugar into those fruit if you
miss that shift
that's where we tend to see a lot of
fruit quality issues begin to develop
and that's where we have problems
particularly with determined tomatoes
where they go through their first
fruiting and they're fruit very heavy
but then they really peter off
throughout the season and struggle to
keep those plants going throughout the
year
um the other ways you want to balance
you want to make sure that your macros
and micros are balanced
we can get deficiencies in both micro
and macronutrients and micronutrients
we're very prone to getting toxicities
the plants do not need much at all for
example boron plants need like a pound
to the acre if you try and feed boron to
your plants it's extremely easy to
poison them accidentally by giving them
too much where it goes toxic
for that reason
micronutrients we try to manage with ph
we optimize ph to manage micronutrients
if you can't correct that with ph
then you would fully fully feed
something like a chelate
chelates are designed to be safe for
plants they're very low application
rates and they're also designed to move
into the tissue and so that's a time
when foliar feeding makes a lot of sense
when foliar feeding does not make sense
it's when you're trying to feed a
macronutrient plants are designed to
take up nutrients through the roots
leaves are designed to keep things out
when you fold your feet a macronutrient
you often get a very quick rapid
satisfying green up effect
but that is temporary
right that's why you have to follow your
feed every week every couple of days
that green up doesn't last and
when we look at the tissue testing when
we look at the research on it we find
that foliar feeding is actually much
more inefficient in terms of
what the plant can take into itself and
incorporate
go ahead marion no it's gonna say you
didn't get one question um if you want
me to interrupt you um can you only feed
through drip and not broadcast any
fertilizer oh you can absolutely
broadcast yeah you can absolutely
broadcast um usually people who are
broadcasting their open field tomatoes
so they're not on plastic or they're
broadcasting before they form up their
beds right because
the question was about not broadcasting
and only foliar feeding right yes i
think so only only foliar yes so
can you only feed through drip and not
broadcast any fertilizer that's the
question ah yes yes you can
and
you can do that
most growers will start off still
broadcasting a little bit
as they learn to manage the nutrition
only through drip so if you've never
done heavy management of nutrition
through drip maybe broadcast some a
little bit to start
people who have been raising in tunnels
or greenhouses for a long time they want
both tunnels they won't broadcast that
much at all if any
and would that depend uh elizabeth on
how whether you had sufficient
nutrients like that soil test that you
showed you you were sufficient for a lot
of nutrients so it seemed as though that
would be a good field to not you know
possibly not broadcast in but but use
the drip more
absolutely and that actually was a test
from a high tunnel that's in part why
the ph was so high okay and so one of
the things that this farm was doing was
they had been adding a bunch of uh
animal based compost year after year
after year and all that dairy manure
drove the ph way up and their fertility
levels weigh up that's why they had so
much excessive calcium and they had so
much excessive phosphorus
higher salt levels and they had really
high ph as a result of all that
composted dairy manure that went into
that tunnel
so in that case yeah they were just
feeding through the drip um
[Music]
tomatoes are really
really well understood in terms of
fertility and their tissue testing
tissue testing is a great tool i
recommend that growers who are
struggling with their fertility tissue
tests at least twice a year so the first
time you want a tissue test
is about four weeks after transplanting
and the second time you tissue test is
when your first fruit are are tiny like
not quite golf ball sized
and so those two tissue tests give you
two very important life stages the
three to four weeks after transplanting
is when that plant is about to enter its
rapid vegetative growth phase and when
the first fruit are not quite golf golf
ball size that's when you're making that
shift out of vegetative focus into
reproductive focus
when you tissue test you want to tissue
test exactly this lab tells you
oftentimes that's taking the first fully
expanded mature leaf that tends to be
about the fifth fleet down from any tip
and you do count the little teeny tiny
leaf um so fifth or sixth leaf down
you want to do it when the plant is it
you know it's got great water status so
that leaf snaps right off and then you
want to make sure that you
rinse anything off of that leaf surface
and then
pat it dry before you put in the bag
it's not hard to do it costs
less than 20 including shipping
and at those two times you still have
the ability to correct any problems and
the tissue testing shows you problems
before you would see it in the plant so
this is an example of a plant where you
definitely would be seeing the issues
you know
big deficiencies in nitrogen big
deficiencies in calcium or potassium
manganese this is that same tunnel that
had the very high ph so we're expecting
a manganese deficiency driven by ph
um excessive levels of calcium as we
would expect from all of that uh the
copper levels this happens when people
forget to rinse off their leaves and so
the copper they're spraying out the
plants stays on the tissue test so you
do have to do a little bit of
interpretation here like oh yes i forgot
that not that i have so much calcium i
forgot or copper i forgot to rinse it
off
but the tissue test tells you things
before you see it particularly for
potassium
and over the course of the season it
becomes a very very good management tool
so the way that we read this chart we
have
five different sampling dates across the
bottom starting in the middle of may to
middle of june or middle of july this is
a high tunnel from a study that was done
a couple years ago we have all the
macronutrients across the bottom the
green is the top of sufficiency range
red is the bottom of the sufficiency
range and you see that the range shifts
the the first solid bars those are for
the vegetative stage and all of these
macronutrients
the plant's physiological need for them
is shifting as it moves into fruiting
and veg and reproductive stage focus
the blue are the levels of nutrition
available in that plant and yes the
tissue test is a look backwards in time
but it is far better than waiting for
the plant to color up by the time the
plant colors up you've had so much
damage that you've already lost the
yield tissue testing helps you prevent
some of that so we saw the nitrogen
levels falling they dip too low growers
changed their fertilizer blend
potassium same thing that started
dipping down they changed your
fertilizer blend um
so it's useful over the course of season
and then
just re-emphasizing that point if you
don't rinse the leaves off you can see
really big spikes in copper and that's
that's just
you spray copper and forgot to rinse it
so foliar testing is a great tool for
nutrient management
i'm really quick and go through
recognizing deficiencies i'm going to do
this quick because there are so many
good photos on the internet um this
panel i have right here is kind of like
it's old it's dated but it is the
classic
panel so it's very easy to recognize
these bows they all have that kind of
fridge magnet style look to it um so if
you're on the internet you're like is
this really that deficiency check it
against these fridge magnet type images
when you're searching
so nitrogen is in mobile nutrient when
it's deficient it's the lower leaves
they're yellow the plant lacks bigger
it's a weak plant very common for us to
see more in tomatoes we see excessive
nitrogen that's where you get this very
dark bushy lush beautiful plant that
doesn't flower that doesn't set fruit
because you've got all this bushy plant
because we tend to trellis our tomatoes
all that material gets packed in it gets
wounded wankers packed in you don't have
good air flow and we see a much higher
incidence of botrytis when we have
excessive nitrogen so managing
nitrogen
is actually an ipm tactic for botrytis
it also tends to reduce the
attractiveness of your tomatoes to
aphids ipm tactic
um this is botrytis
directly attacking foliage but it also
leaves these ghost spots on the fruit
and if you've ever had fruit where it
starts this softer rot off the blossom
end
that's petritus getting in there but
tries to hit the tomatoes at the
flowering stage
and then wait until it's man's mature to
rot it when it goes directly after the
foliage it's very hard to stop and we
can lose tomato crops and tomato i've
seen many tunnels go down to botrytis
potassium is a mobile nutrient this is
the one that you really want to watch
it's very important physiologically for
loading sugar into the plant okay if you
can't have the sugar getting into the
phloem to distribute around the plant
then you're not going to be growing very
well that means you're looking for
scrawny tips to the shoots you're
looking for flower abortion like we see
in this photo here
you're starting to see yellow shoulders
develop on the fruit that are maturing
in really severe cases you'll get a
purpling across the leaf surface the
whole plant is suffering and you can
start to see other secondary nutrition
symptoms show up
potassium is the one
that you're watching with the tissue
test more than anything else because
it's more of an invisible deficiency by
the time you start seeing the signs of
it you've already lost yield potential
and you've definitely lost quality
really poor flavor
yellow shoulders that's usually
potassium a little bit of a magnesium
thing so if your flavor is not where you
want to be
try adjusting your potassium magnesium
phosphorus
um phosphorus is very common it's not
that available in cold soils you
remember earlier i said that
most labs will recommend a little bit of
phosphorus even if the levels are just
out of this
this world sky eye
it's because
cold soils phosphorus isn't it but the
plants can't get it part of that is
because there's a fungal intermediary
that helps to collect a lot of the
phosphorus the soils are cold the fungus
is not all that active
um
it means that it's very common and it's
a temporary thing that we see in
transplants it's a reddening or purpling
on the underside of the leaves you flip
that leaf over and all the veins
are coloring up
we can most easily resolve this by using
a little bit phosphorous in the
transplant water or by using a raised
bed plastic mulch to get it warm now
phosphorus is really important for root
growth so that's why they're
recommending is yes the soils are cold
but we also need to really quickly
establish fruits
so feed the phosphorus early as we go
through the summer their need goes way
down and particularly in tunnels where
phosphorus tends to build way up or in
organic farms we're using a lot of
animal based inputs phosphorus levels
get quite high
um you can pull the phosphorus
completely out of your summer drip
program the soil will supply it
if you have a soil that is very low in
ph or you have soils are naturally very
high in aluminum a lot of shenangos are
very nice agricultural soils but they're
naturally very high in aluminum
know that phosphorus is inhibited by
excessive levels of aluminum in the soil
in those cases when you have very high
aluminum you do want to feed phosphorus
through the summer
and phosphorus is loaded into the leaves
first so
you may see
that color hang on the old leaves you're
checking the new growth for improvement
magnesium
another macronutrient
very very common to see some deficiency
in magnesium
it's a mobile nutrient so the plants
will reallocate from low in the plant up
to high in the plant when they're a
little bit deficient it's intervenal
yellowing so it's spotting between the
leaves with age you can see here they
start to get a little bit of a bronze
spot in the center of that
um purple or bronzing in the center of
the yellow in between the veins that's
magnesium this isn't something to get
excited about as long as it's in the
bottom part of the canopy it's natural
uh you're really wanting that to stay
stay good in the middle so with
magnesium we divide the plant in thirds
if it's in the lower third of a mature
sized plant not a big deal if it starts
creeping up or getting more severe and
heading towards the middle third you
want to be managing that
um elizabeth we're getting
tight on time just to let you know about
two minutes left okay thanks so
just a side by side this is a tunnel
that had a lot of fertility problems
not caused by lack of available
nutrition in the soil but caused by
problems like severe compaction too much
salts they had other factors inhibiting
their fertility uptake so we've got a
severe potassium deficiency once it gets
this bad that's coloring up the foliage
we tend to see it make other nutrient
problems even worse calcium deficiency
will color up the edges of leaf and it's
a fairly bright coloring up of the edge
calcium deficiency does not
um calcium doesn't move through the
plant so you'll see a color one age
group of leaves
the next age group of leaves won't have
it but that age group will never get
better you'll have that for life in that
age group what you're looking is for
improvement
this is magnesium as it gets more severe
and this blossom end rot a lot of people
say it's calcium but it's not it's
actually water you didn't have enough
water to move the calcium to the fruit
so calcium level is fine inconsistent
watering
these are the most common nutrient
deficiencies
they do
lead to weak plants they do cause other
ipm problems as you go down the road
and
once you get these gross overall
nutrient deficiencies just one final
photo you can see all the disease in
here all the decay all the rot
and also some really cute birds so on
that
we're gonna
end the presentation i'll stop sharing
and if you have any questions please
drop them in the chat
so there is one that just came into the
chat um do much soils have an effect on
tomato fertility okay yeah great
question
so muck soil is incredibly high organic
matter soil it's the formed from like
dead plants and trees and stuff really
old swamp
um
because of that it holds so much more
nutrition
per unit of soil so if you have like a
cup of soil it holds much more nutrition
because it holds so much more nutrition
uh
the actual ph because it holds so much
more nutrition because the soil
naturally sits at a lower ph
all of our
values if we say tomatoes like ph 5
there's 6.5 to six eight you adjust that
downwards almost one whole unit when
you're working on muck
and that's because the nature of the
soils a they run more acidic b they can
make up for it by holding so much more
fertility so if you are testing a muck
it's going to
you know show low
that's okay
don't be freaked out by that you do have
to watch some of your micronutrients a
little more closely because some mucks
don't have a lot of that uh depending on
where you are in the state if you may
have a mug that's underlaid by a lot of
calcium and that will change your
fertility management if it doesn't have
the calcium underlay you tend to be very
high in sulfur you need to supplement
calcium there
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu